mr speaker despite this optimistic
backdrop
we must continue to act with caution not
least
because of the renewed challenges posed
by new variants of the coronavirus
we have found here 105 cases of the
variant first identified in south africa
including 11 cases which don't appear to
have any links to international travel
as with the variant first identified
here in the uk
there's currently no evidence to suggest
it is any more
severe but we have to come down on it
hard
our mission must be to stop its spread
altogether and break those chains of
transmission
in those areas where this variant has
been found parts of broxborn
london maidstone southport walsall
and woking we're putting in extra
testing
and sequencing every positive test
working with local authorities we're
going door to door to test everyone in
those areas
and mobile testing units will be
deployed offering pcr tests to people
who have to leave their home for work
or other essential reasons we have also
seen 11 cases of mutations of concern in
bristol
and 32 in liverpool and are taking the
same
approach in all these areas it is
imperative
that people must stay at home and only
leave home where it is
absolutely essential when your local
authority
offers you a test you should take up the
offer because we know that around one in
three people with coronavirus have no
symptoms
but can still pass it on we're offering
testing to everyone age 16 and over
even if you have been vaccinated and if
you live in one of those areas
but have not been contacted and you're
unsure if you should have a test
i encourage you to visit your local
authority website to find
out anyone who must
leave home to go to a workplace for
instance
because they cannot work from home
should get
tested all local employers should
support and encourage their workers to
get tested and the message
is more important than ever to stay at
home
maintain social distancing and get
tested